[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bienvenue dans ces idées qui gouvernent
le monde la France est-elle en train de
perdre l'Afrique une question
d'actualité des pays africains de
l'Ouest mais aussi d'ailleurs en Afrique
se font entendre des noms à la France
s'agit-il de solder notre passé colonial
en Afrique en visant une France Afrique
désormais en morse cérébrale même
l'opération barkhane engageait en 2014
pour empêcher le dépeçage du Mali par
les djihadistes d'acni a pris fin en se
cherchant d'autres missions que
strictement sécuritaire il incompte
désormais à des milices militaires
russes sous le nom de Wagner
d'assurer devrait aux côtés des forces
armées africaines pour assurer une rente
sécurité à des états instables et pillés
en retour les ressources disponibles
s'agit-il
sentiment d'une rancoeur d'une défiance
politique à l'égard d'une France
prédatrice des précieuses ressources et
autres matières premières d'une Afrique
qui demeure un continent pardon
richement doté nonobstant la
paupérisation des populations et un
développement insuffisant à la vérité le
pré carré africain de la France en
matière économique est en voie de
rétrécissement constant au regard de la
mondialisation qui permet à la Chine à
la Turquie au Brésil à la Russie de
s'emparer des marchés africains bref la
France ne semble plus l'Allier
privilégiée de l'Afrique de l'Ouest
d'autres puissances prédatrices se
bousculent dans la salle d'attente
africaine pour quelle finalité politique
et stratégique de ce continent africain
qui en 2050 sa population doublée et
pour quelle politique africaine de la
France nous allons tenter de répondre à
toutes ces questions avec mes invités
que je vous présente Edouard Guillot
vous êtes amiral ancien chef
d'état-major des armées George sers vous
êtes diplomate et vous avez été
ambassadeur en Côte d'Ivoire
Kalix Beyala vous êtes romancière
Antoine Glaser Glaser pardon vous êtes
journaliste et écrivain et Nicolas
Baverez vous êtes avocat politologue et
essayiste
[Musique]
alors vous venez de voir la citation que
j'ai prise qui est de vous Calix Beyala
les rêves de liberté des Africains sont
restés coincés entre les mains des
Francs africains avant d'aborder les
questions de politique d'économie et de
sécurité comment vous percevez la
dimension psychologique de ce
ressentiment anti-français qui se fait
entendre à Bamako à Dakar à Yaoundé
Bangui Libreville giamena
d'abord excusez moi de penser qu'il y a
pas de ressentiment anti-français les
Français en tant que Ted ne te sens pas
persécutés en Afrique on peut être
français et vivre à Douala à Yaoundé
tout à fait on sécurité c'est un
ressentiment
anti-système plutôt anti-France africain
il faut savoir qu'il y a un groupe de
personnes constitué de noirs et des
blancs qui se sont organisés ce
continent donc par faciliter
intellectuelle on dit anti-français on
peut pas être anti-français puisque
quand on veut construire le lumière
quand on dit non à la France ça veut pas
dire qu'on l'embrasse elle veut pas non
plus dire que quand la déteste c'est
quand même assez ambigu puisque la
plupart des étudiants africains veulent
quand même venir faire leurs études
encore en France donc c'est très
paradoxal très ambigu on peut pas
résumer les choses la France doit [__]
le camp et puis la France doit partir et
puis nous on en a assez des Africains ce
n'est pas un support gère les problèmes
je pense que il faut trouver des moyens
de conciliation des moyens de dialogue
il faut évidemment la population dans la
rue n'est pas n'a pas forcément des
outils
n'est plus là la France africaine bien
là à travers des Africains à travers des
Français ils sont ils ont ils tiennent
l'économie ils tiennent leurs sapés ce
sont eux qui contrôlent les choses c'est
pas la France institutionnelle qui est
là qu'est-ce que vous voulez avoir
d'autres avis genre je sais comment vous
appréhendez ce nom à la France qu'on
entend dans ces capitales africaines je
crois qu'il faut quand même savoir
raison garder je suis assez d'accord
c'est pas un c'est pas un nom français
et quand on dit non à la France c'est
une réaction contre une politique c'est
dans un moment bien bien précis dans le
temps et puis ça se passe dans un
certain nombre de capital pas c'est pas
dans toute l'Afrique c'est donc il faut
être un peu plus un peu plus mesuré
quand on a par exemple au Burkina Faso
une attaque contre l'ambassade et une
destruction des instituts français de
Bobo-Dioulasso et de et de la capitale
quelques jours après il y a des
journalistes donc burkinabè mais aussi
ivoirien et d'autres pays qui sont là
qui font une émission et les remarques
qu'on entend c'est quel dommage d'avoir
cassé cet outil de travail qui nous est
utile sur lequel nous travaillons nous
burkinabè nous ivoiriens donc vous voyez
c'est pas non plus c'est une
présentation un petit peu virulente de
quelque chose qui qui alors quand on
parle de France Afrique c'est un concept
qui avait été inventé il y a maintenant
plus de 50 ans par Félix
Houphouët-Boigny ça c'est aussi une
image un moment donné dans un temps
précis alors aujourd'hui ça a été
utilisé par un certain nombre de ONG par
un certain nombre de partis politiques
c'est ça c'est une image angoisse que ça
veut dire mais c'est un peu comme la
girafe c'est facile à on voit ce que
c'est très difficile à décrire
aujourd'hui
mais alors donc ça existe ou ça n'existe
pas Nicolas baverest la France Afrique
je pense que c'est aujourd'hui largement
un mythe mais ce qui est intéressant
c'est de voir pourquoi est-ce que le
mythe aujourd'hui est utilisé en fait
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé hier
finalement eu trois grands moments le
moment des indépendances effectivement
un échec assez majeur de la conversion
de l'Afrique qui était mal parti pour la
démocratie et le développement et c'est
vrai que vous l'avez rappelé c'est
l'époque des années 60 c'est cette
grande époque de la France Afrique
ensuite à partir des années 90 il y a
deux mouvements intéressants il y a une
démocratisation de l'Afrique et puis par
ailleurs l'Afrique entre dans la
mondialisation elle s'ouvre et vous
l'avez rappelé elle a des partenaires
qui se diversifient et on a un troisième
moment aujourd'hui ou en fait en même
temps qu'elle s'ouvrait l'Afrique
n'était avec la fin de la guerre froide
l'Afrique n'était plus un enjeu
géopolitique et stratégique comme on
l'avait connu auparavant elle est
retenue elle est redevenu pourquoi parce
qu'on a une grande pour une passion
entre les démocraties et que pour des
pays comme la Chine comme la Russie
comme la Turquie le fait d'être en
Afrique on va rentrer dans le détail de
ces choses-là ça explique pourquoi la
France Afrique parce qu'il y a une
compétition des puissances aujourd'hui
en Afrique et qu'effectivement un
certain nombre on va rentrer dans le
détail utilise le mythe de la France
Afrique pour le retourner contre la
France c'est ce qui s'est passé au Mali
c'est ce qui s'est passé au Burkina Faso
Antoine glacer la France Afrique à
l'époque du général de Gaulle on
identifié l'Africain du général c'est
déjà Foucart mais aujourd'hui
en disant bah voilà on est dans une bien
sûr que dans une nouvelle période mais
de géopolitique la France n'a pas vu
l'Afrique ce mondialisée tout le monde
regardait l'Europe le la réunification
de l'Allemagne mais qui se préoccupait
de ce qui se passe en Afrique moi j'ai
vu même dans les milieux patronaux les
gens étaient installés en pensant que
c'était aDVITAM eternal et je pense
qu'on paye actuellement se refuse enfin
Emmanuel Macron maintenant il y a eu
Rwanda maintenant il veut ouvrir aussi
les les dossiers sur sur le Cameroun
l'Algérie mais à un moment donné surtout
en 2017 quand il est arrivé au pouvoir
il a dit les gars on replis on remplir
les rétroviseurs regardons devant moi je
suis jeune j'ai pas connu ça allons-y
franchement je pense que c'était une
erreur je pense que il faut parler de
cette période qui était quand même il
faut je termine là-dessus pourquoi
c'était une période particulière parce
que les propres alliés la France
laissaient la France gérer ces pays à sa
guise la France contre les à 50 60 % à
la vie l’uranium le pétrole à bas prix
donc c'était une période qui a la chute
du mur de Berlin on a fait comme si la
France n'a pas vu l'Afrique ce
mondialisée c'est ça le vrai problème
oui alors écoutez amiral vous avez été
chef d'état-major et vous étiez si je
puis dire en opération au moment de
l'intervention servale et barkhane vous
n'êtes pas resté longtemps après comme
chef d'état-major mais vous avez
supervisé est-ce que vous avez ressenti
à ce moment-là une hostilité des
Africains à la présence militaire
française en réalité à aucun moment et
même aujourd'hui alors qu'on a vu
effectivement un certain nombre de de
manifestations dont on sait très bien il
suffit de regarder les drapeaux
étrangers qui sont
[Musique]
montré dans on sait très bien qu'elles
sont téléguidées à aucun moment nous
n'avons eu la moindre
des difficultés la seule véritable
difficulté que nous avons rencontrées
c'était de coopérer avec des armées qui
étaient des armées nationales qui
étaient souvent en réalité laissée pour
compte par les gouvernements locaux dont
on peut dire que d'une certaine façon
alors nous nous étions sans doute un peu
coupable de l'avoir accepté mais eux
trouvaient que c'était tellement
confortable de laisser les Français
faire le travail à leur place donc on a
été très bien reçu la libération de
Tombouctou la libération de Gao menaca
enfin toute cette partie du nord du Mali
mais également
quelques années auparavant quand nous
sommes intervenus dans d'autres pays je
pense à la Côte d'Ivoire et je SERP peut
en parler ça va man nous sommes
intervenus également en République
centrafricaine à peu près à la même
période et à chaque fois nous avons été
très bien accueillis la difficulté que
nous avons rencontrée nous
pas militaire français c'est que assez
souvent nous avons considéré qu'une
opération militaire se suffisait par
elle-même et était un tout en réalité
non il y a un jour avant l'opération
militaire il y a un jour après ça n'est
qu'un moment dans l'histoire d'un pays
c'est un petit moment il faut maintenir
compte de ce qui est avant surtout il
faut préparer la prêt et c'est peut-être
est-ce que vous voulez dire vous voulez
dire qu'avant l'intervention
Serval et barkhane il y a eu une
préparation politique insuffisante
non pas avant l'intervention sur l'avant
de l'intervention l'intervention de
Serval en fait on la voyait venir depuis
quelques années pourquoi parce que les
groupes djihadistes prenaient de plus en
plus d'otages on disait qu'à un moment
ça allait finir par exploser et la
surprise a été que plusieurs groupes
salient alors que d'habitude il se il
se combattait les uns les autres mais
quand ils sont alliés là ils étaient
devenus trop puissants pour le
gouvernement central de Bamako
donc c'est pour ça que nous sommes
intervenus par contre
nous n'avons sans doute pas là je parle
avec du recul et je suis quand même très
prudent préparer la sortie non militaire
de Serval qu'il y ait une sortie qui
s'est appelée barkhane c'était naturel
je pense que c'était vraisemblablement
ce qu'il fallait faire à ce moment-là de
même qu'il est bien qu'on en sorte sans
doute aujourd'hui mais il y a les à côté
les à côté c'était quoi c'était la
reconstruction il y avait plus de
dispensaire le système d'adduction d'eau
Tombouctou avait été détruit qui venait
du fleuve Niger il y a quand même 40 km
c'est nous qui avons remis des pompes
mais ça ne suffisait pas et nous n'avons
pas
réouvert ou aidé suffisamment réouvrir
les écoles ça c'est pas directement les
militaires mais nous faisons partie d'un
tout qui s'appelle la France
nous n'avons pas du coup donné les
moyens
aux agriculteurs de pouvoir recultiver
leur champ ou faire paître leur troupeau
pour les éleveurs
mon petit commerce de se réépanouir aux
écoles de réouvrir et je pense que c'est
souvent là que nous avons par peur
d'être accusé de néo-colonialisme alors
justement à ce sujet George sers vous
êtes le diplôme
dans cette assemblée là
il y a beaucoup de puissance européenne
qui ont colonisé des pays en Afrique et
ailleurs que ce soit la Belgique que ce
soit la Grande-Bretagne que ce soit
d'autres pays même l'Allemagne etc
finalement le colonialisme français
c'est une repentance
inextinguible est-ce qu'il y a à votre
avis quelque chose dans ce domaine
de morbide ou de pervers est-ce que
jusqu'à quand faut-il expier d'avoir été
colonialiste alors moi j'étais
ambassadeur en République démocratique
du Congo et qu'est-ce que c'est
confortable d'être ambassadeur de France
en et République démocratique du Congo
puisque c'est la colonisation belge qui
est critiquée tous les jours donc vous
voyez tous est relatif encore une fois
je remets les il faut remettre les
choses en perspective quand on est en
Tanzanie on parle encore de on parle
encore aujourd'hui des de la
colonisation allemande qui fut terrible
quand on est au Cameroun la colonisation
allemande a été effectivement très dure
aussi mais il reste des choses et dans
certaines régions du Cameroun on parle
encore allemand enfin il y a des il
reste quelque chose donc là aussi on a
des moments historiques et on peut pas
mesurer à l'aune d'aujourd'hui ce qui
s'est passé autrefois et on n'a pas fait
pire que le commande Noël a fait pire
c'est encore aujourd'hui même si c'est
de manière virtuelle
comme son nom l'indique c'est une
association économique
la France a essayé d'être l'économie et
la politique en particulier la France a
essayé d'être un peu plus loin dans
l'esprit des Lumières c'est-à-dire
d'avoir quelque chose qui soit plus que
de l'économique alors c'est là qu'elle a
peut-être pêché par orgueil peut-être
été un peu plus loin que ce qui pouvait
être fait en fonction de ce qui existait
mais en même temps bon il reste aussi il
y a vraiment de très beaux restes de ce
qui s'est fait en Afrique en Afrique
francophone et d'ailleurs quand on est
en Afrique du Sud beaucoup de
Sud-Africains les Alliances françaises
en Afrique du Sud c'est le pays du monde
où les français se développe le plus
parce que d'abord les gens ont envie de
faire du commerce avec le reste de
l'Afrique une partie de l'Afrique et
francophone donc ils vont ils vont
apprendre le français quand on est quand
on est canadien par exemple on voit très
bien aussi que la langue française on a
dans le cadre de la Francophonie et
quelque chose qui est assez porteur et
puis on est à 850 millions de
francophones dans le dans son projet de
temps dans 30 ans dans 20 ans 25 ans 30
ans dont une grande partie d'Afrique du
continent africain donc voyez tout ça il
faut pas le voir de manière aussi aussi
brutale c'est pas c'est pas
l'un ou l'autre c'est c'est beaucoup
plus nuancé Nicolas pas vrai je voulais
dire un mot sur la repentance
inextinguible non enfin ce qu'à la fin
des temps
ça n'a pas de sens on voit aujourd'hui
qui a un ressentiment et seront
sentiment c'est vrai qu'il est paradoxal
parce que les puissances coloniales
aujourd'hui en Afrique c'est en Chine il
y a kawaii c'est la Russie il y a qu'à
voir ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
en République centrafricaine
ou au Mali et c'est plus la France donc
dans l'héritage de la France évidemment
il y a un passé qui est un passé violent
conflictuel il y a des instruments vous
l'avez rappelé moi je voudrais quand
même revenir sur le fait qu'il y a des
instruments qui sont très utiles parce
que l'avenir de l'Afrique c'est
l'intégration on a le grand marché
africain mais on a des instruments
d'intégration qui viennent donc la
langue française qui est la langue
officielle et qui permet de dialoguer
sur une partie du continent il y a le
franc CFA qui permet de rentrer
le droit des affaires qui qui
progressent donc il y a quand même des
instruments d'intégration qui existent
et qui sont positifs mais le cette
logique du ressentiment je pense que de
toute manière on construit on construit
jamais l'avenir sur le ressentiment mais
comme il a été dit pour dépasser le
ressentiment il faut pouvoir
s'expliquer communiquer c'est ce qui a
été fait entre la France et c'est ce qui
peut tout à fait être fait par ailleurs
et comme Wells n'est pas non plus un
enfin tout ne va pas si bien que ça dans
le commonweal alors Kalix il faut qu'on
essaie quand même de purger la question
mais je peux avoir parce que le
populisme
l'autorité le nationalisme sont partout
dans le monde et on le constate de plus
en plus et si vous me permettez je
dirais que l'Afrique n'y échappe pas
comme tous les continents il y a partout
cette montée de populisme et de
nationalisme est-ce que vous n'avez pas
le sentiment qu'en Afrique la vindicte
anti-française est constitutive de ce
populisme et de ce nationalisme est-ce
que est-ce que vous avez pas ce
sentiment là alors je sais bien qu'un
nationalisme se construit par rapport à
un autre nationalisme comment vous
expliquez que c'est le sentiment
anti-français qui nourrit dans ce cas-là
le nationalisme avant de vous répondre
je vais vous rassurer sur ce plateau le
continent africain notamment l'Afrique
francophone ne connaîtra plus
l'impérialisme je pense que ce qui est
en train d'être fait est fait pour que
plus jamais
aucun peuple que ça soit la Russie que
ça soit les chinois ne puissent dominer
il y a un travail qui est fait et
j'aimerais que vous m'écoutiez un tout
petit peu ce que vous appelez
ressentiment c'est que l'histoire n'a
pas été purgé je m'explique monsieur
c'est que par exemple dans le cas du
Cameroun on a eu un colonialisme on a eu
la guerre moi j'ai vécu cette guirlande
enfant je veux dire que j'ai vu des
morts j'ai vécu dans des cadavres entre
0 et 15 ans en suspendait des armes je
ne sais pas ce qui s'est passé et
jusqu'aujourd'hui personne ne m'a dit ce
qui s'est passé et j'aimerais beaucoup
qu'on me le dise
ce qui se passe c'est que les Africains
ne veulent plus de ces dénominations
d'une monnaie qui s'appelle le franc CFA
on va rentrer dans le détail de
l'économie mais restons sur les aspects
psychologiques puisqu'on a déjà abordé
ces questions je préfère
il faut bien que c'est pas des
nationalistes qui se construisent en
Afrique c'est du panafricanisme qui est
en train de se construire c'est à dire
que nous sommes en train de vouloir
mettre à plat même les nationalismes ça
nous sert pas les nationalismes puisque
ça draine des haines ça traîne la
xénophobie en Afrique du Sud on peut
tuer d'autres Africains en Guinée
équatoriale on peut enchasser d'autres
on n'en veut pas ne suivez pas la rue la
rue n'a jamais construit une nation ce
sont les élites qui construisent une
nation et ce que nous voulons faire ce
n'est pas des nationalisme ce n'est même
pas dit français parce que si on faisait
une organisation anti avec des
ressentiments on va se purger ça on veut
le dialogue avec la France là dessus
pour trouver des solutions car ce que
nous voulons fabriquer tous aussi quel
presque 15 millions d'afrodescendants
qui sont français et donc cette Afrique
là ne pourra pas se construire sans
cette France là mais euh se focaliser
sur des gens qui hurlent dans la rue
vous m'avez pas vu hurler avec eux vous
n'avez pas vu ce qui baptise l'Afrique
de demain hurle avec eux ce ne sont que
des hurleurs laissons le faire leur job
et ce n'est pas pour autant qu'on va
remettre en question un tout il y a des
choses belles qui se font il y a des
choses qui n'ont pas été très bien qu'on
peut érectifié rectifiant-les sur le
plan économique même si le plan de la
Francophonie qui a été complètement
perverti qui était un organisation
culturelle d'abord linguistique qui
était là pour que les peuples échangent
et une plateforme culturelle on en a
fait un instrument politique du coup ça
a éloigné les peuples de la Francophonie
et ça concerne que vous êtes politique
et on en a marre conçu un projet
monsieur oui par rapport à cette
Francophonie qui a été adopté et qui n'a
pas été mise sur pied depuis 2002 c'est
ce qui a été adopté par les 56 états et
aucun État ne le pratique on est parti
chercher des femmes qui ne pas même pas
le français pour nous incarner mais où
nous sommes nous monsieur il est temps
que on règle les choses et moi je tiens
à ce que ça aille bien vous savez
pourquoi parce que mes descendants sont
de ce pays et si ça va mal avec
l'Afrique je ne sais pas où ils vont
aller donc nous n'allons pas nous
focaliser sur les hurleurs les noms à la
croix on vous a entendu
[Musique]
Nicolas baverest vous avez entendu Kalix
Bayala l'Afrique ne veut plus d'aucun
impérialisme et l'Afrique se veut
souveraine elle veut être libre de créer
sa monnaie de commercer avec qui elle
veut d'élargir ses partenariats à sa
guise est-ce qu'elle en a les moyens
tout à fait oui puisque aujourd'hui si
vous voulez le quand on regarde et c'est
vrai sans doute ça a été comme il a été
dit très mal compris par le la France
l'Afrique elle fait partie du Sud global
en réalité l'Afrique elle sait largement
déjà émancipée quand on regarde le
développement qui a eu lieu depuis les
années 2000 alors qu'il y a buté sur la
pandémie surtout qui bute aujourd'hui
sur la crise alimentaire mais c'est un
continent qui a enfin décollé qui a une
croissance de 5,5% par an et ce qui est
intéressant
quand on va de très bas c'est pas comme
2% quand on va on est très haut oui mais
la dynamique si vous voulez ce qui est
important c'est que quand la croissance
économique devient supérieur à la
croissance démographique ce jour-là
incontestablement alors ce qu'on peut
critiquer ça a été dit c'est que ça
c'était valable pour le continent c'est
56 pays très différents donc évidemment
dans ces pays vous en avez qui ont 10%
de croissance
effectivement le Rwanda le Wanda ou
autre il y en a sur lesquels c'est
évidemment beaucoup plus compliqué
notamment dans la zone subside mais ce
qu'il faut bien comprendre c'est que là
où se développements est intéressant
c'est que c'est un développement qui
était assez largement autocentré c'est
un développement qui a été assis sur le
développement des villes un début de
constitution des classes moyennes une
diversification des économies donc en
réalité l'Afrique elle a effectivement
une démographie extrêmement dynamique
elle a des ressources majeures et très
importantes elle a des problèmes de
sécurité des problèmes de transition
climatique mais en tout cas aujourd'hui
les Africains et les Africains se dotent
des moyens de leur développement je l'ai
évoqué tout à l'heure le le par exemple
la zone de la grande zone de
libre-échange panafricaine c'est un
instrument qui est extrêmement puissant
donc le français est faille il faut être
clair le français c'est quelque chose
qui appartient aux Africains si ils
veulent justement sortir
si vous regardez par exemple le problème
donc aujourd'hui il y a deux problèmes
en Afrique la crise alimentaire et la
dette elle se règle le plus elle se
règle le plus à Paris et à Bercy la
dette africaine elle est essentiellement
entre les mains de la Chine alors
justement George sers
répondez-moi clairement sur un point
précis est-ce que on peut supprimer le
franc CFA est-ce que ça est-ce que ça
aiderait
l'Afrique à avoir sa souveraineté
économique dans les statuts du faux
monétaire ce qui est recherché par le
Fond Monétaire c'est une cohérence
globalisée des financements des budgets
donc ce qui se retrouve effectivement
dans les dans les zones monétaires comme
la zone euro aujourd'hui la zone euro
dont d'ailleurs fait partie la zone CFA
est on peut on appelle ça la zone CFA
mais c'est une zone ça fait partie de la
zone euro c'est un élément de la zone
euro donc la tendance c'est privilégier
des rassemblements dans lesquels on peut
effectivement
mutualiser un certain nombre de
financement un certain nombre de
budgétisation et la preuve c'est que si
le Mali et la Centrafrique aujourd'hui
peuvent encore payer les fonctionnaires
d'une certaine manière c'est parce qu'il
faut partir de la zone franc et que
quelque part les mécanismes donc ça veut
dire qu'il faut le garder pour le moment
en Afrique de l'Ouest le débat qui s'est
posé aujourd'hui c'est au sol la CEDAO
de la monnaie qui s'appelle l'Echo donc
la première phase de l'écho aujourd'hui
c'est la consolidation de l'Union
économique et monétaire ouest africaine
c'est à dire le CFA d'Afrique de l'Ouest
en ce qui concerne le CFA d'Afrique
centrale bon bah il est là il est pour
l'instant il fonctionne il est et puis
il faut pas oublier que dans cette zone
euro il y a la zone franc d'Afrique de
l'Ouest d'Afrique centrale il y a aussi
des Comores et puis les États du
Pacifique loué c'est un peu plus un peu
plus large que ça mais ce qu'il faut
bien retenir c'est que l'objectif du
Fond monétaire c'est d'avoir des
éléments comme ça et ça va dans le sens
de lasler la zone économique globale de
l'Afrique parce que effectivement
économie autocentré mal ouverte encore
sur la mondialisation 5% 6% à peine du
mot commerce international aujourd'hui
l'Afrique il faut qu'elle commerce entre
elles
quand on se projette sur la le futur il
y a une zone moi j'aime bien le rappeler
aux gens parce que tout le bassin au sud
du fleuve Congo ce sont des terres qui
sont à 300-400 mètres d'altitude il y a
de l'eau c'est le futur grenier de
céréales du monde la nouvelle Ukraine la
nouvelle Ukraine tout à fait très belle
formule quelque part c'est là qu'il va
se passer des choses pour tout ça est
encore ouvert mais ça voudra dire que
les gens doivent s'entendre entre les
engueuler parce qu'il faut avoir des
lignes de chemin de fer qui vont sur
l'Atlantique il va falloir s'entendre
avec les Congolais avec les uns et les
autres donc quelque part c'est comme ça
que ça va fonctionner il faut aller vers
alors on passe du CFA aux stratégique
amiral d'un point de vue stratégique
même si la division du monde n'est plus
à l'homme de la guerre froide
on a eu la crête sanitaire on a la
guerre en Ukraine il y a un espèce de
clivage qui s'observe entre l'Occident
et les puissances
autoritaires pour ne pas dire
anti-démocratique est-ce que vous pensez
qu'aujourd'hui l'Afrique risque de
basculer de ce côté là
je ne crois pas comme le disait madame
Bayala tout à l'heure les Africains
veulent être par eux-mêmes et vivre par
eux-mêmes et si nous d'un point de vue
stratégie militaire nous sommes restés
peut-être trop à l'intérieur de la
sphère militaire en oubliant l'extérieur
d'autres font une tentative Wagner ça
n'est pas seulement une milice de
mercenaires c'est d'abord un système
économique comment est financé Wagner en
République centrafricaine et au Mali par
des contrats sur les mines les mines
d'or les mines de tout ce que vous
voulez les mines de sel y compris
Wagner se paie directement si j'ose dire
et pardonnez-moi l'expression sur la
bête
je pense que ça ça ne peut pas
fonctionner ça ne peut pas durer en
Afrique la Chine elle est arrivée
uniquement comme bailleur de fonds
comme bailleur de fond et quand on va
George sert connais bien Kinshasa il y a
deux quartiers chinois à Kinshasa qui
sont totalement isolés et qui sont à la
limite
si les Chinois faisaient des bêtises je
parle du gouvernement chinois je parle
pas des de ceux qui sont sur place qui
seraient finalement des otages des
populations locales oui mais qui
s'inssemble se ressemblent connaissait
ce proverbe oui bien sûr qu'ils
assassinent est-ce qu'une présence
chinoise très forte une présence russe
forte une présence turque forte etc
n'amènera pas un basculement aussi
de régime est-ce que vous pensez pas ça
je pense que de même que nous allons
peut-être commis l'erreur nous Européens
occidentaux de vouloir faire
exporter directement nos propres
systèmes politiques sur une Afrique qui
avait d'autres traditions ancestrales
ethniques et je pense que c'est les
Russes ou les Chinois voire les Turcs
qui sont vraiment trois systèmes
totalement différents font sans doute la
même erreur le l'avenir politique de
l'Afrique il se fera par les Africains
pas en
plaquant finalement ou en imitant avec
des conditions
en réalité de pression et de température
qui sont totalement différentes Antoine
glacer de ce que vous savez de ce qui se
passe en Afrique est-ce que vous avez le
sentiment que la Chine la Russie dans
leur coopération avec l'Afrique apporte
de la prospérité à ce continent et de la
stabilité politique je reviendrai dans
la il faut savoir si on critique la
France Afrique comme on le fait si on
considère qu'il faut revoir la politique
de coopération est-ce que la
mondialisation aujourd'hui
profite à l'Afrique à travers les
échanges avec la Chine la Russie la
Turquie le Brésil bien sûr la
mondialisation la veille guerre
mondialisée j'ai pas répété la même
chose mais c'est vrai que il faut qu'on
sorte de cette période historique qui
était justement cette période
en Afrique et les Africains qu'est-ce
qui se passe au niveau des matières
premières et autres c'est vrai que
l'erreur de la France pas vous avez dit
tout à l'heure par rapport aux Anglais
les Français ils ont eu alors pour le
meilleur et pour le pire c'est vrai que
c'était toujours une colonisation c'est
on aimait que les Africains qui nous
ressemblaient c'était une politique
assimilationniste en Afrique les Anglais
c'est le pire est le meilleur le pire
c'est la partie en Afrique du Sud le
meilleur c'est chacun dans son club les
Ghanéens quand vous avez les filles de
shebok qui se font enlever au Nigeria
vous avez jamais entendu un problème
ministre anglais qui s'en occupait en
dehors de Michel Obama qui disait mais
je vais dire chacun il faut arrêter de
penser qu'on peut faire un le bonheur de
l'Afrique et il faut laisser l'Afrique
aux Africains
africains Kalix Baya là vous vivez à
Paris je crois
de ce que vous savez et de ce que vous
entendez est-ce que
la présence chinoise
la présence russe l'amiral Guillot vient
de dire que les Russes à travers la
sécurité de Wagner se paye en payant les
mines est-ce que vous avez le sentiment
que ces puissances comme la Chine la
Russie ne se comporte pas comme des
puissances prédatrices comme on a accusé
la France Afrique de l'être est-ce que
l'Afrique est immunisée contre ses
prédations en quelque sorte d'abord ce
qu'il est important de savoir ce que les
Africains ne connaissent pas les Russes
même si Wagner résistent on ne les
connaît pas on ne connaît pas les
Chinois non plus c'est à dire ils
viennent là peut-être faire leur route
ils vivent dans leur coin il y a jamais
il n'y a pas de contact en tant que tel
entre j'ai vu aussi en Afrique parce que
c'est très important de le dire je vis
la plupart du temps en Afrique depuis
quelques années dans quelques pays dans
quel pays au Cameroun au Cameroun le
billet essentiellement au Cameroun je
connais très bien la centrale puisque
mes frères sont généraux ou même en
Centrafrique en ce moment donc je
connais très bien la situation ça te
fait également ou Guinée équatoriale bon
on ne les connaît pas déjà c'est à dire
que ce qui est important de dire c'est
que la relation avec la France paraît
beaucoup plus violente pourquoi parce
que c'est une relation un peu plus
fusionnelle c'est-à-dire que c'est une
relation qui date comme un vieux couple
qui est là depuis des décennies des
générations qui a produit des enfants
des petits enfants et évidemment c'est
pas qu'une relation avec quelqu'un qu'on
ne connaît pas je veux dire les
Africains connaissent les Français les
Français ne connaissent pas les
Africains là c'est là où on a d'abord
péché c'est-à-dire
en France on n'a pas eu la curiosité de
connaître les Africains on a même choisi
en France c'est même pas seulement de la
simulation liste les africains les plus
faibles la France a toujours travaillé
avec les populations africaines enfin
choisis parmi nous les éléments les plus
faibles or les éléments les plus faibles
sont des éléments dangereux excusez-moi
de le dire comme ça ce sont eux qui
qu'on a mis en place ces éléments
dangereux qui ont créé la situation
actuelle qui ont payé les pays parce que
quand on parle de la France Afrique et
qu'on ne veut pas du français pas c'est
à cause de de l'obscurité autour de
un système opaque voilà et donc le
peuple ne veut ne veut plus de ça et
pourquoi ça s'est passé comme ça on a
des dictateurs en place évidemment c'est
la France qui les a mis en place en
choisissant les éléments les plus
faibles qui n'ont jamais eu le courage
d'affronter leur peuple d'affronter les
difficultés que rencontrer leurs peuples
moi je me parle la responsabilité
seulement sur la France mais sur
nous-même aussi c'est-à-dire quand vous
allez au Cameroun ils sont là depuis 60
ans ils n'ont rien fait la misère est
essentiellement la cause de ce
ressentiment que vous avez les Africains
sont pauvres ils sont riches et pauvres
à la fois on a quelques familles qui ont
tout le reste qui mange du soleil qui
boit du sable et c'est ça le vrai
problème euh c'est pas la démocratie le
problème en tant que tel c'est la misère
Nicolas Bapt après
juste voilà prolonger ce qui a été dit
parce que et aussi dans la continuité ce
que vous avez dit c'était l'Afrique aux
Africains évidemment dans ce sens où
comme tout
tous les pays toutes les nations tous
les continents c'est un des nations et
des continents des peuples qui ont
vocation à prendre leur destin en main
en revanche je pense que la France mais
on a beaucoup parlé de France mais c'est
l'Europe plus fondamentalement la France
et l'Europe ne peuvent pas se
désintéresser de l'Afrique parce que
parce que vous l'avez dit vous l'avez
dit il y a des liens humains permanents
il y a des enjeux qui sont permanents on
sait que la percée du Jihad en Afrique
ça a des conséquences immédiates sur
l'Europe on sait que si le développement
échoue évidemment il y aura des
problèmes de migration majeures on sait
également que c'est si les choses à
l'inverse fonctionnent bien c'est le
grand continent émergent du 21e siècle
et donc c'est pour ça que il faut
imaginer des logiques de
co-développement et d'une certaine
manière dans ces logiques de
co-développement c'est pour ça que moi
je sais que économiquement le gros
problème du franc CFA en réalité c'est
pas que c'est un instrument d'un
perviste c'est que comme il y a le lien
avec l'euro c'est une monnaie qui
surévaluée donc qui pose des problèmes
de compétitivité mais à l'inverse il a
cet avantage qui permet à des pays de
travailler ensemble et de commerce
regardez le contre-exemple c'est le
Maghreb le Maghreb c'est une aberration
qui est pas un grand marché du Maghreb
on a des pays qui s'opposent et c'est un
obstacle majeur au développement donc
vous voyez c'est pour ça que les choses
sont compliquées parce que l'Afrique aux
Africains évidemment au sens où c'est
évidemment pas à la France d'aller
choisir les dirigeants ou d'aller
intervenir
on ne peut pas et on ne peut pas perdre
l'Afrique et on ne peut pas à l'inverse
laisser des puissances comme la Chine ou
la Russie donc la Chine c'est la
dépendance à la dette la Russie c'est
très violent et c'est Wagner la Turquie
c'est la religion mais on ne peut pas
laisser c'est pas laisser mais nous ne
demandent pas l'autorisation
et on est bien d'accord il y a une
compétition et il faut qu'on joue le jeu
d'aujourd'hui
les forces armées africaines
sans censés s'occuper de la sécurité du
continent africain on dit quels sont
dans l'ensemble corrompu
est-ce que c'est exact et dans ce cas-là
à qui revient d'assurer la sécurité du
continent africain non mais j'allais
elles sont corrompus c'est pas c'est pas
les armées qui sont corrompues ce sont
des systèmes il y a eu toute une période
où finalement la France était un peu
substituée aux armées les Africaines
nationales dans cette période voilà au
niveau de ce qu'on appelle ces périodes
postes coloniale c'est vrai que les
présidents comme Houphouët-Boigny
préféraient avoir une garde
présidentielle avec les Français il
préfère qu'il soit les Français qui
assurent ça sécurité avec le 43e Bima
donc je veux dire c'est aussi d'abord
c'est vrai qu'on parle on est là pour
parler de la France en Afrique mais il y
a une responsabilité énorme bien
évidemment des dirigeants africains les
dirigeants africains ils ont peur et à
juste titre pour certains de coup d'État
de leur militaire donc pendant très
longtemps il préférait demander à la
France à cirer leur sécurité plutôt qu'à
de former leur propre leur propre
officiers donc je vais dire mais encore
une fois vous avez il faut quand même
comprendre ce qui se passe en Afrique
vous avez toute cette zone depuis la
Mauritanie jusqu'au Soudan c'est il y a
plus de il y a plus d'Occidentaux ça
veut dire ils ont réussi les djihadistes
mais c'est pas simplement le djihadistes
c'est parfois aussi des réseaux
islamistes plus ou moins radicaux
peut-être de saoudiens peut-être des
Qatariens et autres qui font du
prosélytisme aussi dans toute cette
région donc vous avez comme ça de cette
zone on est dans une nouvelle période
historique alors il y a évidemment que
les Chinois eux ils font l'économie la
Russie va faire surtout la sécurité et
aussi à certains types de matières
premières et aussi pouvoir aussi vendre
des petites centrales nucléaires à
l'Afrique mais je veux dire on est il
faut vraiment voir ça avec un grand
angle et comprendre que on n'est plus on
parle du CFA mais finalement ce qui
défendent le CFA c'est parce que le CFA
est politique il est économique mais il
est il reste aux yeux la salle est très
politique ce sont les dirigeants
africains et vous allez pas pouvoir
renverser les les états c'est il faut
laisser du temps au temps il y a un
certain nombre de jeunes africains ça va
se développer il y aura des
bouleversements comme on a vu il y a ces
derniers jours en Chine les choses
évoluent aussi ils les choses évoluent
mais nous on s'est mis quelque part
hors-jeu parce qu'on voyait pas les
enjeux localement on ne sait un peu
endormis on s'est endormi dans une
Afrique qui était plus la nôtre et on
s'est cru encore chez nous voilà c'est
tout mais il faut laisser du temps au
temps et il faut laisser l'Afrique se
développer et je suis complètement
d'accord avec Kalys benyala que personne
ça sera pas plus faut arrêter de dire
aux Africains attention les Chinois vont
vont vous exploiter attention les
saisons laissez-le moi j'aimerais un
jour faire un livre en disant
démerdez-vous je vais dire on les
Africains se démerder avec avec
l'affaire merci
[Musique]
bien je ne sais pas si on va reprendre
la formule
d'Antoine Glaser mais en tout cas on
parle beaucoup de démographie en disant
qu'en 2050 il y aura 2 milliards plus de
2 milliards d'Africains est-ce qu'à
votre avis Calix Beyala l'Afrique est
prête à faire face à cette montée
démographique et surtout qui pour
assurer son développement quand on voit
certains chercheurs comme Stephen Smith
qui considère que ce qui quitte
l'Afrique sont souvent des gens de
qualité et bien formés
bien je pense qu'on parle de l'avenir et
du futur oui absolument je suis
conscient qu'il y aura deux milliards
d'Africains en 2050 et je crois que
c'est une très bonne chose parce que à
tout boom et économique précède un boum
démographique on avait on peut pas faire
des étapes par exemple en Guinée
équatoriale avec 700000 personnes qui
consomment personne on peut pas faire
des états avec un million de personnes
il faut savoir que l'Afrique pour
l'instant est sous peuplé ce n'est pas
ça le problème et dynamique d'ailleurs
parce qu'on a une jeunesse énorme enfin
énorme quand on a 40 ans en Afrique on
est presque trop vieux les autres vingt
ans voilà et c'est formidable et
contrairement à ce qu'on croit c'est que
les gens sont hyper formés vous prenez
un pays comme le Cameroun si vous leur
donnez des instruments même pour faire
des microprocesseurs et vous le feront
tellement on a formé nos enfants au
niveau notamment du Cameroun on a créé
des nous-mêmes des universités c'est pas
l'état partout on a formé nos jeunes
donc ils sont prêts c'est que donc en
fait aujourd'hui c'est peut-être des
hommes pour impulser tout ce que tous
ces toutes ces choses c'est-à-dire par
corrompu pas qui dorment chez eux pas
qui est 90 ans au pouvoir et qui puisse
permettre à l'Afrique de démarrer et ça
va se faire parce que vraiment dans la
nouvelle génération il y a des gens de
qualité la deuxième chose c'est que
l'immigration est toujours eu lieu et
c'est une bonne chose pour tout le monde
et j'espère que il y aura aussi de
l'immigration de de la France de
l'Europe vers l'Afrique c'est un jeu
c'était un jeu permanent et c'est ça qui
a permis à l'humanité d'évoluer il faut
qu'on évolue tous et qu'on dépasse
certaines choses non on dirait pas
l'Afrique démerdez-vous
parce que la France aura aussi besoin de
l'Afrique nous aurons besoin les uns des
autres c'est pour ça que moi ce discours
de Noël la première dont nous
de dirai et je pense que le plus urgent
aujourd'hui pour la France c'est de
d'impulser un dialogue avec avec les
Africains c'est ce qui manque de les
écouter et qu'ensemble on a entendu
à suivre George sert est-ce que vous
êtes aussi optimiste par rapport au défi
démographique
parce que la résilience en Afrique c'est
quelque chose de formidable et si tu as
fait d'abord c'est tout à fait humain
c'est comme ça que l'humanité c'est
créer depuis 100000 ans en fait depuis
et ça pince vient bien d'Afrique enfin
tout le monde le dit aujourd'hui alors
un pays comme le Niger à chaque fois
dans les gens regardaient par exemple en
1950 les gens disaient les économistes
500 000 personnes au Niger c'est pas
praticable ça ne pourra jamais suffire
et ainsi de suite la Banque mondiale dit
en 1975 plus de 6 millions au Niger
c'est pas possible parce qu'on a déjà
brûlé tout ce qui était autour de Niamey
aujourd'hui il y a 20 millions
d'habitants et il y a pas il y a pas eu
de grandes familles depuis maintenant 15
ans les grandes familles c'était lié à
des sécheresses donc quelque part il y a
une résilience il y a des gens
apprennent à cultiver quand on joue on a
parlé tout à l'heure de grenier futur de
l'Afrique donc moi ça ne me fait pas
peur au contraire c'est un atout d'avoir
cette cette jeunesse en plus les gens se
débrouillent aujourd'hui les grandes
villes les grandes villes comme les
gosses ou Abidjan les grandes les gens
se débrouillent parce que ils ont ils
ont ils ont intérêt à survivre en
utilisant des moyens à la fois modernes
et des moyens traditionnels donc ils
continuent à cultiver des plantes
anciennes mais en même temps bien ils
vont tourner vers l'informatique moi
j'ai vu effectivement dans certains pays
des jeunes qui avaient été à peine formé
sur l'informatique par des gens un peu
plus âgés et aujourd'hui qui a été
capable de construire des ordinateurs
C'est ça la vraie Afrique c'est comme ça
qu'elle va ce que vous en pensez à Miral
la transition démographique je suis
surpris et agréablement surpris par
plusieurs phénomènes il y a 20 ans
m'expliquait que à cause de l'épidémie
de sida la population d'Afrique allait
tomber en 2020 serait en dessous de 500
millions d'habitants bon déjà les
démographes et les épidémiologistes ce
sont largement trompés du coup les deux
milliards je me pose la question sera
peut-être un milliard et demi seulement
les efforts mais pour aller encore assez
régulièrement en Afrique je je suis
toujours enthousiasmé il y a pas
d'autres mots par la volonté de la
jeunesse je donne des cours dans une
université
qui est à 150 km de Dakar qui est celle
de Bambi où l'on forme des jeunes pour
les besoins locaux pas pour aller les
exporter aux États-Unis ou en Europe
mais bien pour les besoins
du Sénégal voir d'autres pays donc
intellectuellement tout y est y compris
la volonté
c'est vrai par ailleurs que ça
bouillonne parce que il y a 70% de la
population qui a moins de 30 ans donc
c'est assez naturel c'est vrai que c'est
assez pratique de de trouver un bouc
émissaire c'est et la France Afrique en
est un j'ai bien dit la troisième
période de la française Afrique comme
disait Nicolas baverest on est loin de
la première
d'un autre côté c'est à nous
d'aider les Africains à acquérir les
bons instruments c'est pas vendre c'est
pas ça il s'agit de les aider
s'il le souhaite et avec eux et non pas
de leur dire voilà votre solution ça ça
ne marchera pas et du coup oui on y
arrive c'est vrai y compris au point de
vue sécuritaire
la sécurité ce qu'on oublie de dire un
peu c'est qu'un certain nombre de chefs
d'État africains sont d'anciens
militaires c'est la raison également
pour laquelle une fois qu'ils sont au
pouvoir ils ne veulent surtout pas que
leur armée soit compétente puisqu'ils
ont peur d'être renversés par un autre
par un autre militaire
d'où et nous revient à ce qui a été dit
déjà deux fois ce soir et bien on
déléguait la sécurité plus ou moins à
l'ex puissance coloniale je pense que ce
ce temps est passé maintenant et que les
nouvelles générations ne l'accepteront
plus et c'est tant mieux ecoutez il
aurait très peu de temps je voudrais
l'Afrique c'est un très grand continent
avec au nord un pays comme l'Algérie au
sud de l'Afrique du Sud
tout ça est très complexe et désafrique
on a très peu de temps peut-être en une
minute chacun d'entre vous qu'est-ce
qu'il faut qu'est-ce qui souhaitable au
niveau de l'Afrique est-ce que c'est un
une union africaine comme il y en a
comme on a fait l'Union européenne mais
qui a des défaillances on le constate
aujourd'hui sur notamment sur la
question de l'énergie à votre avis
qu'elle veut vous formuler à ce sujet
c'est le vœu des peuples d'Afrique que
je veux former c'est à dire on veut du
panafricanisme c'est-à-dire la
construction des États fédérés
gouvernement
le peuple africain et pas parler pas
parler pas parler dirigeants mais tout
le peuple de ce qu'il veut le
panafricanisme et c'est très facile
pourquoi parce que en dehors de l'arabe
dans le Nord le reste de l'Afrique en
fait il y a que trois grandes langues ce
sont les langues des Bantous les langues
à claques de l'Afrique australe et les
langues de l'Afrique de l'Ouest avec le
full B donc c'est très facile donc on a
déjà on a déjà très en avance on a
travaillé sur ces langues on a choisi de
parler par exemple l'arabe le français
l'anglais le swahili et le fullbé ce
sont les 5 langues que nous avons choisi
pour cet Afrique de demain donc nous
sommes déjà très avancés on a déjà
travaillé sur les socles communs de ce
que nous devons avoir en commun au
niveau de de la pensée enfin merci parce
que un mot là-dessus alors il y a un mot
parce qu'il nous reste plus longtemps
premièrement l'Afrique va être le seul
continent qui va être en expansion et
qui va être en continent jeune dans un
monde qui va beaucoup vieillir
deuxièmement c'est vrai que c'est la
logique de l'intégration qui est la
bonne et tout ce qui peut la promouvoir
y compris autour des des pays qui sont
les pays un peu structurants
c'est-à-dire Nigéria Afrique du Sud
Egypte Algérie Maroc et la dernière
chose je le répète c'est que ce que vous
avez appelé dialogue on peut l'appeler
qu'aux développement mais c'est un enjeu
vital pour la France et pour l'Europe et
on ne peut pas s'en désintéresser et
autant l'Afrique se déverser par
elle-même mais elle ne se développera
pas seule non plus merci Antoine Glaser
très bref en tant que Français moi je
pense que c'est vraiment l'heure
d'apprendre de l'Afrique de s'intéresser
vraiment à l'Afrique des Africains ça
veut dire de pas arrêter les leçons etc
mais de s'intéresser on a trop longtemps
exporté dans ces pays
n'ont pas simplement de constitution et
la langue il faut apprendre de l'Afrique
s'intéresser à l'Afrique pour se caler
réellement et vraiment il y a un gros
travail à faire il y a quelques
chercheurs qui le font ils sont rien
mais très peu merci amiral Guillot
là-dessus
si l'on considère je crois que c'est le
cas autour de cette table que le
continent majeur du 22e siècle sera
l'Afrique c'est donc au 21e siècle qui
va prendre
et que nous nous sommes plutôt sur une
pente descendante c'est une simple
observation et bien à Lyon nous ne
laissons pas passer le train et les
Africains le méritent votre vœu africain
je sers pour compléter ce qui a été déjà
dit donc laissé aussi aussi la place au
financement du secteur privé pour que ce
secteur privé qui est le moteur de la
fric aujourd'hui le vrai moteur de
l'Afrique c'est le secteur privé puis se
développer de manière harmonieuse et
solide écoutez merci Madame merci
Monsieur on se lassera jamais de faire
des émissions sur l'Afrique avant de
nous quitter je voudrais vous signaler
une bibliographie alors
Kako nubucco ce qui est un ancien
ministre
vient de publier un livre une solution
pour l'Afrique est-ce que vous l'avez lu
madame Beyala non pas encore mais je le
lirai avec plaisir vous le lirez avec
plaisir alors je vous l'offre avec
plaisir voilà Kalix Beyala vous vous
avez publié un ouvrage qui s'appelle
alors j'ai choisi ça le Christ selon
l'Afrique en un mot c'est quoi le Christ
selon l'Afrique mais parce qu'il y a des
églises réveillées maintenant il y a des
poissons à tous les coins de rue et des
prophètes et c'est
spirituel pour l'Afrique donc c'est de
ça dont je parle merci je voudrais
également signaler un livre qui vient de
sortir qui est assez exhaustif sur la
l'Algérie de l'Algérie du 19e siècle du
20e siècle et du 21e siècle de Pierre
Vermeeren histoire de l'Algérie
contemporaine alors nous avons également
je voudrais signaler votre livre Antoine
Glaser que vous avez fait avec Pascal
Hérault on a déjà parlé ici le piège
africain de Macron est-ce que vous
pensez que Macron apprend de mieux en
mieux à connaître et à gérer l'Afrique
oui parce qu'on l'entend de moins en
moins donc il a compris que l'Afrique
valait faire un voeu de silence et on
l'entend bien ben écoutez voilà une une
observation Nicolas baverrez l'alerte
démocratique vous pensez que la
démocratie est en danger vous avez
publié ça aux éditions de l'Observatoire
on a toujours besoin d'agiter ce drapeau
démocratique à plus que jamais
la liberté n'est jamais donnée c'est un
combat et en ce moment c'est un combat
qui est de plus en plus compliqué c'est
vrai en Afrique c'est vrai surtout les
sur tous les continents merci merci
Madame calixba yalla merci messieurs
d'avoir participé à cette émission je
voudrais remercier notre excellente
équipe à LCP et avant de nous quitter
vous
laissez avec cette réflexion de Pierre
de Villiers qui a également été chef
d'état-major des armées je crains que le
désengagement français n'accélèrent une
déstructuration de certains pays
africains au profit de puissance comme
la Chine et la Russie
[Musique]